all right we're now live for another
live reading from my book uh reason
fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
christian philosophy debates in france
published in 2011 containing a number of
translated documents from the christian
philosophy debates
and
my
roughly hundred page historical and
thematic introduction and then a
extensive bibliography that was current
back in 2011 and of course
is not today
except for going back to the 1920s and
1930s so this is the second to last
session
and we're going to be reading from the
final maurice blondell piece there's
four pieces by maurice blondell
in this
volume in part because he was one of the
most overlooked uh untranslated
members of the debate i didn't actually
translate everything that he wrote
there's other things as well but we're
going to be looking at his foreign
integral philosophy published in the
review neo scholastic philosophy if you
remember last session we read fear
non-fun steinbergens a piece also
published in review neo-scholastic to
philosophy and then
next week we'll be finishing up by
reading leon noel's the notion of
christian philosophy also published in
that same journal which you can tell
assumed in
significant importance during the
debates later on so
good to see you here mark and hey hello
to everybody else
um so let me jump then to page 260
in the text
and this is a um
there we go
this is a 1934
piece so we're getting close to the end
point of the debates in 1936.
maurice blondel foreign integral
philosophy
mr fernand von steinbergen's vigorous
article seems to be of the right sort to
clarify the formulation of a problem so
complex that it has perhaps been a
mistake to call it the problem of quote
christian philosophy a term that is
highly equivocal in the use that has
been made of it and that strictu sensu
remains inevitably
hybrid
that author by the conciseness of his
criticism and the direct character of
his own assertions usefully dispels
certain misunderstandings and raises
some reflections
certainly of profit to many
in many of the objections he sets forth
on the desiderata that he expresses he
seems to me to concur if not with the
formulation he gives his thoughts at
least with the basic exigencies
justifying his severity
still though since his critiques and
assertions seem to me at times
unjustified or capable of false
applications
it will undoubtedly be useful to discuss
certain theses that one by one seem to
augment or lessen the truth of what we
may still
despite everything call quote catholic
philosophy
number one
first a preparatory remark that although
it seems only to touch on a question of
terminology already contains an early
indication of the confusions from which
we need to free ourselves in place of a
mingling of words that not without
reason he judges equivocal and formally
erroneous mr von steinbergen substitutes
another expression in place of christian
philosophy
he proposes philosophy of christianity
let us examine this suggestion which in
the recent debates and among so many
attempts aimed at more closely grasping
the solutions correct formula
is offered to us for the first time
this appellation proposed in order to
avoid an ambiguity is it not just as
ambiguous as the one it would replace
it seems that it admits of two
completely different meanings and
i add from this point on
two meanings just as denaturing to the
doctrine that one aims thereby to
safeguard by the analogies that he
invokes philosophy of science philosophy
of history of religion etc
our author inclines us to interpret the
words so associated as if it were a
matter of reflection on the christian
religion considered from the outside and
without an internal relation with the
specific content of revelation
but aside from the fact that the term
philosophy of history is poorly thought
of at present because the speculations
placed under its rubric were shown
more and more to falsify history without
contributing any philosophical
illumination or certainty
the analogous expression proposed to us
is even more hybrid more compromising
for the object it is charged with
designating with a clarity that will
legitimate this expression
such an expression simply from the
rational point of view would it not
deserve it all the discredit with which
the philosophy of history
is rightly tarred a philosophy that
lived or died by tendentious
considerations no longer those of
impartial history
nor of philosophy organized in a
technical and professional manner
can the rational and completely
extrinsic examination of the gospel
message of supernatural truths of
christian life in the church or in souls
respect both the specifically divine
character of christianity and the
completely human character of philosophy
do not the ambiguities certain
historians of metaphysical thought are
criticized for turnip multiplied here by
the very fact that philosophy is
explicitly called upon to consider the
christian religion
as a contingent and historical datum by
heaping up extrinsic considerations that
cannot possibly ascend to the christian
religion without forcing it to descend
to the level of natural facts and
without even attempting the least
speculative penetration
no doubt this restriction prevents
confusion
but whether one would like it or not it
consecrates separation
but one will respond
does not the contested expression admit
of a more intrinsic meaning a direct
fundamental critical examination of
christian data that reason would
consider from its autonomous point of
view
does such an interpretation distinguish
itself from the historical or
historicist theses that mr von
steinbergen has demolished with a
correct and penetrating severity
from such a perspective either
philosophy commits suicide by placing
itself in vassalage to what we must call
the not only transcendent as such
philosophy calls it but specifically
supernatural character of positive
religion
or
it is christianity that succumbs by
allowing itself to be sliced up and
assimilated by a critique applied to
dogma to christ to the church
setting aside whatever by hypothesis by
hypothesis and definition remains
incommensurable with philosophy and in
its supernatural reality inaccessible to
consciousness direct observation as well
as to reason's verdict
in both of these possible
interpretations
the recently proposed mixture of words
seems more than deficient and if some
people have come to suggest and be
content with them
perhaps it is because despite
well-favored efforts to approach the
question center the vital point were all
the difficulties to be resolved or bound
together in a not has not yet been
concisely perceived nor
truly touched on
two
rather than seeking partial concordances
or even rational superimpositions and
coincidences between a philosophy and a
christianity that after being
encountered in a contingent way would
get boxed up one inside the other by
alternatively using them as content or
container
it is on the contrary a matter of
constantly laying out and safeguarding
this double truth without ever taking
anything away from it without concealing
any of it and without forgetting any of
it
on the one hand
between the christian order and the
philosophical order there is an
essential
incommensurability
one such that reason could never
discover exhaust
perceive assimilate or substitute for
the mystery of truth and grace that is
hidden in history and that the gift of
the redeemer makes universally radiate
on the other hand whether in the absence
of known revelation or under the light
of divine teaching philosophy which
cannot penetrate the secret of the
supernatural order
can still however prepare the
dispositions required so that entrance
to the invisible soul of the church
remains open to all
through the intellectual moral and
religious preparations that its mission
is to illuminate and to verify as if in
the role of precursor
philosophy has the duty to maintain
ready and free the place of waiting or
possession
only christianity
deserves and fills
how can we not see how much the true
problem
is denatured by putting philosophy and
christianity into competition so to
speak as if the former had to supply or
submit to the positively supernatural
fullnesses religion provides or imposes
when it is really a matter if one may
say this of a double emptiness to
prepare
for
quote god loves empty vessels
empty and pure so he can enter there and
god according to saint john's expression
emptied himself as it were so that we
could enter into him by restoring to him
with full offering of ourselves that
part of divinity he has lent us with the
alternative of a possible day aside or
of a union transformative even to the
point of theosis
there is therefore a radical
impossibility of confusing philosophies
and christianity's roles and in fact the
attempt at a rational concordance is
absolutely chimerical and deadly when
substituted for the search for a mutual
penetration and union in the most
jealously maintained incommensurability
such an
unconfusability is of metaphysical
necessity and to not bring it up at the
beginning of the problem to be resolved
is not only to close off the entry door
but to run into an impenetrable wall
three
assuredly mr von steinbergen does not at
all intend to misrecognize the
reservations i have just pointed out nor
to confine himself to a fixture of more
or less superimposable or
interchangeable concepts he protests
strongly against the attitude of certain
philosophers of history who take a
peculiar position
by conceiving a philosophy in itself
stabilized and closed off notions
seeking their ideological constructs
material solely in the past
as if what lived no longer had any need
to live and to move through present or
future initiatives
simply from reason's point of view can
we call intelligible and satisfactory a
metaphysics drawn up short at the always
deficient idea we have of god a
certainty whose firmness would be
without any internal dynamism an
aspiration that would not move toward
beatitude
also despite the strange assertion of
certain philosophers who acknowledge the
quote insufficiency of philosophy
without accepting a philosophy of
insufficiency
it is possible to show the verbal and
chimerical nature of such a distinction
which far from penetrating to the ground
of things
risks despite denials to the contrary
leading us into a separated philosophy
self-sufficient and excluding any
conception or any welcoming
of the supernatural
let us rejoice then to hear mr von
steinbergen state that philosophy is not
a closed circle in the order of beings
of reason of intelligible possibilities
or essential necessities for he says
quote philosophy is the scientific
effort which aims at general
explanation of the real
and to better indicate that even in this
very reality philosophy does not ignore
concrete elements partly escaping
through their condition as individual or
through their transcendence the science
of the general he admits as father
sertianj and i had asked that philosophy
is not only insufficient and far from
being stabilized but also
capable of justifying and using this
given fact in order to raise it to a
norm and establish a philosophy of
insufficiency only
it is not enough to accept this
assertion in principle
nor to leave it among all the other
concepts in the inert condition of a
general and static thesis since it is
aroused by the total dynamism of the
human being and since it is the
expression of a congenital and
incoercible desire in every created mind
so different recent critiques not that
of mr von steenberg and remove
from this acknowledgement it's
stimulating a salutary virtue
setting it out like a nightlight or even
extinguishing it by avoiding seeing
whence it comes and whether it goes and
integrating it in philosophical thoughts
on life they do not notice that they
annihilate it by going back to just to
seeking out notions common to theology
and philosophy and in place of the
living problem of the relations between
philosophy's goal and the drive from
which inquiry proceeds along with the
demands of religious aspiration and
supernatural vocation
they substitute the abstract relation of
two competencies two disciplines
considered in a completely formal manner
on the ground of abstract knowledges and
methods to be distinguished
doubtless these analyses are legitimate
and even necessary but philosophical
criteriology is not the living thought
that animates philosophy and sets it
within a drama
any more than theology is the
christianity vivifying souls and bearing
salutary truths divine demands and
eternal responsibilities
it is there however that the problem to
be resolved resides a problem whose
aspects critical reflection will have to
analyze but without reflection by itself
procuring its effective solution
still must we restrict the solution
only to this simple opening that
theoretically in the order of
possibilities rational speculations
insufficiency faced with a certain
notion of god with our ignorance of our
final destiny with our vague aspiration
towards beatitude imposes on us
it is here that i no longer quite
understand how mr von steinbergen
maintains coherence between these
affirmations he has insisted on the
extension of philosophical doctrine to
all the real
then he restricts the scope of rational
speculation to the domain of concepts of
essences of possibilities of
metaphysical
necessities and it is from that point on
that he just as much as anyone else
begins to eliminate the study of the
historical psychological moral and
religious facts
as if philosophy went outside of its own
power and its duty by going beyond the
analysis of the state of pure nature in
order to research whether in the
concrete order something other than the
perfect autonomy of a state of nature be
found
a state that not only has not existed
and does not exist but that an
essentially philosophical matter
cannot be conceived as a final fixed
state in any created mind
while arming ourselves better than many
have done against the def deformation or
mutilation that tomism suffers from that
point on when one eliminates the reality
of the dynamism intrinsic to every mind
is eliminated and from that point on
when the intellect is fixed in its
concept of god
this other scholar without realizing it
returns to the idea of a philosophy
restricted to concepts and to concepts
restricted to logically defined contours
but contours foreign to the domain of
concrete existences of life in movement
of real infinitude even if it be that of
god who always remains beyond our ideas
and our grasps
at that point after having accepted the
notion and legitimacy of a philosophy of
insufficiency
he reduces this assertion to something
purely static conceptual and even
negative
it seems to him that after having
admitted its rational powerlessness
there is nothing more to do than to halt
philosophy at the threshold of a
naturally obscure and unsoundable abyss
he does not envision the possibility of
considering the gap that the admission
of our deficiencies implies as a
positive state as the expression of a
presence of a power of a duty of our
thought
interiorly belabored by a very real
aspiration
by a historically set out vocation or
even by a
an undeclinable grace
from such a point of view what does it
become the teaching brought back to
light the teaching of the
zitarim natarala vivendi dayam from
which not only the patristic tradition
but the scholastic tradition draws
inspiration
four
one might still object that under the
pretext of not confusing theological
synthesis with christian reality we
ought not identify philosophy with the
rational life nor attribute it to it the
value of a drama since in place of a
denumont it has only a theoretical
explanation to offer an illogical and
metaphysical ordering to establish
but
through this resistance useful for
preventing deplorable confusions we risk
falling back again into that narrow
conception we claim to exclude and
exceed the conception of a system of
ideas that deliberately leave outside
their embrace
this living and concrete reality that we
had promised not to neglect
to take account of this we do not in any
way have to identify philosophy with
lived and thought reality entirely to
the contrary we insist on the
inadequation between philosophical
science and concrete reality vast enough
and complex enough so that the order of
nature does not remain essentially
impenetrable to stimulations of a
superior order this is why we speak of a
philosophy of insufficiency in a more
precise
more positive sense than as if for the
human mind it was a matter of a pure
nature that in actuality has never
existed and this for a double reason
for no spiritual creature can remain
fixed and satisfied by what it knows of
itself and of god without being
belabored by a natural desire reasonable
and inefficacious to reach god
and be attitude
also and still more man originally
invited and called by redemptive charity
to a supernatural destiny
cannot be complacent in an only apparent
com apparently complete and
comprehensive realism that would
eliminate the psychological
moral and religious realities resonating
even if only anonymously
at the bottom of even the most ignorant
consciousnesses according to one of
deschamps remarks
mr von sjane bergen rightly explains to
us that beyond a theology strictly
confined to the rational organization of
the truths of faith there is what he
names a broad theology that embraces and
dominates in an immense intellectual
synthesis all of the lights and the
living forces of general civilization
nothing better if in the name of a suma
constituted as a function of the
instruments prepared by human culture he
retains the plasticity of an organism
that assimilates its feedings and
renewals necessary at every age of life
but conversely since he recognizes
philosophy's spontaneity and autonomy he
doubtless also admits for it the good of
a growth of a broadening capable of
digesting and enlivening more and more
widely extended acquisitions
precisely because we have shown that
even in theses reason and revelation
work on simultaneously there is a total
heterogeneity of origin method of scope
of spirit we need not fear collisions
and confusions
for philosophy has only to remain
faithful to its light courageous and
conquering in its line of aim as true
and as complete and comprehensive as
possible in order to sustain if one may
say so
the development that in a different
plane theology whether strict or broad
pursues without impatiently seeking an
imposed concordance
from such a point of view certain
criticisms that mr von steinberger
addresses to an article published in v
on celexual do not seem valid against
the reverend father certian's central
thesis
they would bear against him only to the
degree to which his urbanity seems to
agree to certain concessions to the
theses shifting in any case of certain
of this debates protagonists
but from that point on when one
recognizes philosophy as a legitimate
extension to the entire range of the
real not only of an ideal being but of a
psychological and historical concrete
it then seems consequent and even
indispensable to attribute to this
complete and working philosophy a triple
field of study without which far from
fulfilling its normal and beneficial
function
it runs the risk and we with it and
through it of instituting between it and
christianity not a regime of alliance or
of union
but of tendencies oscillating back and
forth between ursulations conflicts
separations and exclusions
five
what seems to make all of our
controversies obscure and to lead leave
us into an inextricable confusion is the
temptation to juxtapose totally
heterogeneous data without going back up
back and up to the dominating principle
that alone can prepare and realize union
without confusion
of philosophy history dogma and
christian life
each of these elements admits of being
studied under two aspects and the
equivocation that must be everywhere
destroyed is that which would identify
the historical fact in time and space
with the super temporal and extra
spatial act from which christianity is
essentially constituted
it is through this reality antecedent to
facts and visible to discursive thought
transcendent to metaphysical reality
itself that we must gain access to the
center of perspective
outside of which everything remains
mixed up and insoluble in the living
problem of our unique and indeclinable
destiny a problem from which philosophy
cannot be totally dispossessed
but which cannot present itself to
philosophy except under an aspect
completely different from that of facts
understood in space and time
from ideas analyzed and organized by the
understanding from simply psychological
and social considerations
this is why the order according to which
one approaches the different data of the
problem is of sovereign importance for
the solution's value this sort of
organization and subordination it seems
has not been sufficiently taken into
account
judging juxtaposing the heterogeneous
data of the most complex of problems
therefore is not sufficient by such a
method one can only oscillate between a
confused reconciliation and distinctions
transforming themselves into cloistering
separations
this isolation just as much as this
fusion leaves us in every case in the
unexplained and the extrinsic
in order to take account of religious
demands of metaphysical precisions of
historical data of psychological and
moral experiences how can philosophy
proceed
without compromising the meaning of its
research the forward movement of its
inquiry the scope of its conclusions
three levels seem necessary to cross
through not at all by an arbitrary
succession but according to bacon's
expression
uh peregratus debitos
a let us first render satisfaction to
the legitimate need and to the
traditional effort of a metaphysical
speculation that dominates
all conceivable hypotheses
what are the necessary conditions that
render possible the existence and the
destiny of minds
this study of intrinsic necessities and
consequently of realizable possibilities
excludes the errors on which the most
autonomous philosophy renders its just
verdict
in this way room is made for truths that
while often unrecognized are subject to
every fundamentally true doctrine a real
distinction between the essence and the
existence in every creature even the
most spiritual one the truth of creation
that completely unrecognized by the
ancients does not allow itself to be
does not allow itself not to be
rationally accessible
the ability and the duty for the mind to
recognize that god is just as to affirm
also that he is our principle our end
the desirable source of happiness
admission of incommensurability between
god and the creature and consequently
natural inaccessibility for man to the
union in assimilation with god
so many truly philosophical assertions
prepare or even impose the idea of the
supernatural as desirable obscurely and
inefficaciously wished for as it is
conceivable
will we deny that in an autonomous way
intellectual speculation opens up the
empty space very usefully and that if
revelation can serve as a ramp it is not
revelation that supplies the strength
nor sets one climbing the stairs
and we understand that in agreement with
tradition eminent theologians indicate
quote the place of the supernatural in
philosophy under a doubtless
indeterminate but still very character
characterized form
in this way
even in the order of essential
possibilities and metaphysical
necessities the idea of a philosophy
stabilized in concepts is absolutely
untenable
one can affirm it only in a purely
terminological manner by taking words
that seem clear and by imagining in them
limits that materialize spiritual
realities and god
be
but from the moment when the most
autonomous and the most developed
philosophy is led rationally to
recognize man's powerlessness both to
limit his drive toward infinity and to
arrive at the possession of this supreme
object
can we render ourselves disinterested in
the question of knowing
whether in fact the idea of the
supernatural responding to this normal
need is accessible by grace if a real
access has been gratuitously and
historically given by god if the truth
of a revelation and of a divine
elevation of man can be envisaged
recognized utilized without that reality
once proposed or even imposed
encountering any legitimate opposition
and philosophical reason
and since mr van steinbergen declares
that philosophy actually has complete
and comprehensive reality for its object
must he not
logically make in some way the
historical moral supernatural truth of
living christianity enter into the
philosophical organism itself
let us remark here that it is not under
its empirical aspect that the christian
teaching integrates itself within
philosophical thought but
by what is always mysterious in its
supernatural formality
for insofar as supernatural the
supernatural is never perceived by
consciousness nor discerned by
reflection itself always incapable of
reconnecting the anonymous fact of
consciousness to the dogmatic aspect and
to the intimate action of grace
if there is then a marriage of nature
and of christ it is always beneath the
veil and far from violating the
tutillary obscurity
philosophy must preserve it and justify
it by maintaining even in its
initiatives most faithful to divine
stimulations into the light of
conscience the incommensurabilities
between nature's drives and charities
demands
this is why the expression christian
philosophy is more contestable more
equivocal than that whose usage i have
proposed and which mr van steinbergen
rejects perhaps without justifying his
condemnation of an expression whose
meaning and whose reason for being have
seemed to escape him
if revelation is indispensable for the
christian mysteries reality being known
justification remains universally
accessible by the soul of the church to
all those who do not sin against the
light and against the interior call
even if it be anonymous by presenting
itself under form sufficient to a
supernaturally salvific option
and as no man is absolutely deprived of
this possibility of salvation we can
therefore call catholic the disposition
of mind and of will that a philosopher
entirely faithful to his ability and to
his duty can effectively determine in
whoever remains docile to conscience's
solicitations
also it is legitimate to call catholic
philosophy the doctrine that makes
precise the attitude necessary and
sufficient for a human being to be able
to participate in the invisible soul
of the universal church
even if this being would remain without
fault on his part ignorant of christ of
his truth and his law
in his sense we understand that without
knowing the empirical history of
christian facts a person a philosophical
doctrine can correspond to the
ontological history that constitutes the
order of grace by gratuitously
supernatural elevation and redemption of
the creature
it is therefore not with a theoretical
possibility the virtuality of an
obediential potentiality that philosophy
must finish while closing itself off to
all curiosity to any reality responding
to reason's uncoercible wish not at all
does what is normatively possible and
factually desirable or even desired find
itself realized in some way accessible
to our knowledge set effectively in our
scope these questions cardinal deschamps
pointed out emerge from a reasonable
being's gut feelings and it remains
reasonable to examine by every means
whether a solution can be offered
whether one effectively exists whether
in the case of silence we have to adopt
an attitude and conformity to the
mystery that renders our consciousness
restless and elevates it
who would dare to say that no methodical
examination no rational investigation
can extend itself philosophically to the
proposal to the discussion of such
questions
even when an explicit solution cannot be
formulated with precision let us not
pretend therefore that a philosophy of
insufficiency remains confined to a
vague and sterile concept let us not
deny the reality of the invisible soul
of the church a dogma whose oral
confession would be undone by a refusal
to examine what for invincible ignorance
open supernatural access to salvation
let us not neglect to analyze the
reasons of hypothetical necessity the
first vatican council affirms when the
constitution defeated declares that in
the case which is our own where the
positive vocation of man to supernatural
union has been gratuitously realized and
imposed the knowledge of this historical
and psychological truth necessarily
supposes an explicit revelation
what is necessary
derives from a rational analysis and
sense speaking hypothetically the
supernatural vocation is recognized as
possible
there are therefore consequences reason
can analyze in order to enrich the very
notion of a possible revelation of a
human obligation and of a rigorous
responsibility
all of these are truths that follow each
other in a strictly rational plan
and whose philosophical connections we
could still develop
c
if philosophical inquiry without losing
its specifically rational character can
extend itself not to the contingent
modalities of the evangelical message
nor to the dogmatic content of revealed
teaching
nor to the discoveries of redemptive
charity but to the metaphysical and
spiritual core framework that sustains
we can say the ascensions of the
christian order
is there not still a further progress of
philosophical penetration up to the
domain of christian practice of the life
of grace of those mores that in man
himself incarnate incarnate or imitate
the divine morris
saint bernard pointed out that in the
theateric life there is that is a
reality the two spouses without
confusing their being and action do not
make two different parts of the work to
be accomplished said oprah individual
totem singularity per agunt
and what is true of the ground of the
operation is true in another way of the
consciousness we have of it deschamps
insisted on this double fact
supernaturalized virtues are in so far
as supernatural unknowable as
such
but they do not cease for that reason
being human conscious under their
psychological and moral aspect
accessible to a description of the most
delicate and newest nuances of a
perfection that a natural morality would
be by itself unable to attain
is there not something real something
concrete something humanly lived in that
and if philosophy must extend itself to
the entirety of what is true and lived
must to close off its gaze from what is
most beautiful in humanity
therefore
just as speculation can from its
rational point of view
welcome the lights that manifest
metaphysical secrets correlative to the
specifically christian truths without
intrinsically deriving from them
there are in consciousness as dormant
seeds seminal virtues that fertilized by
grace which is less a creation than an
elevation of pre-existing or embryonic
faculties present to philosophical study
a marvelous harvest from which the
science of human resources can
legitimately enrich itself
one can go even further in the same
direction for there is an aspect of
union with god and of the mystical life
that does not at all escape
philosophical analysis
since philosophy applies itself not only
to the possibles to essences to concepts
but to all the realities raised in the
concrete offered to our experience and
constituting the lived history of souls
the spectacle and the practice of a
christianity known and lived all the way
to its peaks procures a philosophically
assimilable surplus of ideas of feelings
of aspirations it is good to make actual
for in the light of faith certain truths
not entirely impenetrable to thought
contribute a rational solution to only
half glimpsed problems
certain delicacies of feeling certain
heroisms certain sacrifices enrich human
consciousness by making moral effort
profit from grace's aid and sublimities
and it is very important that in a
society that christianity has secularly
worked on and elevated a philosophically
attentive critique prevent a double
abuse
first that which would consist in
secularizing and monopolizing the
specifically christian virtues as if
they resulted from a natural progress of
civilization second that which to the
contrary would consist in judging
chemical or inhuman the humility the
asceticism the follies of the cross
all these aspirations and these
immolations that have possibility and
signification only by grace and in view
of the supernatural elevation of man
six there's a little six there mr von
steinbergen who has spoken to us of
broad theology stretching his gaze and
his control over all intellectual
culture and all civilization would he
not accept following our preceding
explanations
one just as favorably envisaging a broad
philosophy which faithful to its formal
and rational principle
extends itself as far as the universe as
far as humanity as far as the soul of
the church as far as man without ceasing
to be man can go towards his supreme
destiny
if he attributes to theology a right of
total perspective without recognizing
thereby the autonomy of any of the
sciences and natural disciplines
is it not logical to welcome also the
idea of a philosophy that by a
reciprocal benefits from its rigorous
point of view envisages a field of
metaphysical truth of historical reality
of enlivening charity by one word
without justifying this exclusion
mr von steinbergen dispenses with the
expression catholic philosophy which in
any case was not under discussion at
juvensie
however according to a remark of saint
augustine himself is not this term more
comprehensive
and more precise than all the rest since
it is applied to complete and
comprehensive truth under whatever
aspect one envisions envisages it
he objects to us that it suffices to
speak of true philosophy constructed
outside of the knowledge of christ but
is it true that we could make a complete
and comprehensive use of our reason or
of our will without encountering without
implicitly resolving the problem that
puts into questioner attitude towards
him even if unnamed who illuminates
attracts and strengthens everyone coming
into the world
there are some faithful among those whom
one calls in fora
infidels and it is not without sinning
against the light that they can be they
can be condemned
in excusables the title christian in so
far as it refers directly to historical
reality
is actually too restrictive and it
applies to some who do not merit it the
title catholic which some reproach me
for having used in two apparently
equivocal senses
embraces to the contrary the entire
truth
from some point of the horizon and under
some anonymous form whatever it may be
ideas and persons who participate in a
right direction in a good intention in a
salvific aspiration
we have said that revealed assertions
and philosophical theses never fuse in a
material concordance this fundamental
restriction does not prevent but rather
permits the double use of the word
catholic understood in a unique sense
as what concerns truth that is life
given but diversified in what bears on
the methods and the paths of access to
salvation
what would drag in ruinous confusions
would be the obstinacy that would make
want to make a philosophy a fixed mass
of concepts to be made to agree with
christian dogmatics
but the true philosophy is to the
contrary that which not only remains
open and plastic but contributes to the
entirety of life to illuminate it just
as to be illuminated by it
therefore as much as we can associate
ourselves with mr von steinberg and
severity against the false concortism of
christian philosophies just as much and
more
it would be wrong and fatal to isolate
anew the two spiritual powers who would
claim autonomous and exclusive rule
over minds and souls
no more than that of concordats the
regime of separation is not normal or
wise what is true is at the same time
and together a heterogeneity and a
spontaneous and meth method methodical
cooperation
if philosophy
ignores or eliminates the intellectual
or moral dispositions that respond to
the demands of faith
it is not true it becomes harmful
in order to help us understand the
delicate equilibrium of attitudes to
reconcile
mr von steinbergen proposes to us an
allegory that of a spectator who
completes his direct vision of a far off
horizon with that of a map where the
various objects to be discerned are
found
but this is again a visual concordance
that does not get us out of a single and
same order of similar data another
analogy would seem to be in greater
conformity to the exact complexity of
the problem
words are sung with the accompaniment of
the orchestra without the libretto i do
not discover the signification or even
the exact words
but the visual images without adding
anything to the sonorous images since
they are of another order
still give to what i hear already and to
what i could even taste with that
understanding enough
a precision a beauty a perfect certainty
perhaps despite the deficiency of the
comparison
we might say that the interior and far
off song of reason and of grace is not
however entirely indecipherable and
without efficacy
but the revelation and the very
spectacle of the church
procure to those who receive its
benefits the means of discerning the
exact meaning of reasons lessons
and of divine solicitations without for
that reason the calls or the responses
the efforts or the aids being confused
or being made of double use those that
in different ways contribute to the sole
truth the sole destiny the sole solution
these brief remarks will suggest the
idea that the problem of catholic
philosophy already usefully illuminated
by so many efforts is not as cut and
dried and simple as many are brought to
believe today
it seems we must divide the difficulty
and examine it along several super
imposed planes
so
that's the end of maurice blondel's for
an integral philosophy i was smiling a
little bit because you know we're 44
minutes into this these brief remarks
right
uh they're not really brief remarks
there's a lot packed in there i do want
to say something too before i i well let
me say hello to everybody who's weighing
in here blondel
not only
wrote that by dictation
and had to because he was nearly blind
at the time
he's responding to other people's
pieces
that he also couldn't read that were
read to him by his secretary
who he then would you know dictate to
blondel must have had a very prodigious
not only memory but capacity for
connecting and associating
all these things in his mind because
even you know even having translated
this and reading it aloud i have a hard
time keeping all the things straight
that he's saying let alone their
reference
in other people's writing so it's pretty
incredible this you know what blondel
was able to accomplish
um
i mean he he his vision started failing
him in the 1920s
and um
you know he's found his secretary who he
can work with by this time
thomas says was blondella practicing
catholic was he going to mass receiving
communion yes very much so as a matter
of fact many of the main people involved
in these debates were um either
and
jacques moratan and gabriel marcel other
really important um people in the
debates all lay people all very devoted
catholics
mauritan and
marcel both converts actually
blondel and and uh jill so and be what
we call cradle catholics both of whom
decided to instead of like going into
the catholic ghetto of the institute's
catalyque or things like that decided to
participate in the very secular
anti-catholic
french philosophical establishment
blondel actually considered a priestly
vocation for a while
and then decided to become what he
called a lay apostle in philosophy
so yeah
mark says uh two broad questions
what do i think blondel's biggest
contribution to these debates across
these four readings
stressing the importance of a philosophy
of insufficiency of you know that that
blondel was working with this from the
very beginning in oxy 1893 and then in
the letter on apologetics um you know
during the modernist crisis
he stressed that
philosophy if it was going to be
genuinely philosophical did need to
exercise its own autonomy not only in
relation to religion but also in
relation to other fields so he would
have been you know against say like the
um positivist project or anything like
that and he knew positivism not through
the logical positives but through
compton and his successors
um
and so philosophy needs to be truly
aware
of its own
insufficiencies its failings the gaps
within it and that is what opens it up
to the possibility of assimilating what
it can learning from
uh christianity the supernatural right
without that blondel thought you wind up
in a couple different problematic
aspects you notice he talks a lot about
conceptualism or buttoning itself up in
concept
but also taking in revelation as one of
the great uh uh metaphors that he has
like a packet of wounding spines right
uh think about taking a sea urchin and
shoving it into your flesh
right so i would say that that is
probably the most important
um contribution and that's recognized by
many of the other people in the debates
you notice um
desolage you notice certions you notice
all these other people that i haven't
put in the book because uh you know they
we can only translate so many and put
them in there uh that's what they
recognized
um mark says do how do his ideas and
these contributions relate to his ideas
conveyed in oxy in 1893 and the
interesting correlations yeah you could
say that blondel's project
begins before accion 1893 which is of
course his second dissertation he has to
write a french dissertation and a latin
dissertation at the time
and oxy 1893 is his uh his french
dissertation
it almost gets him blackballed from
teaching because uh people feel that
he's smuggling in religion but he's
trying to show that philosophy
if it takes itself really seriously
has to extend itself to and has to open
itself up to the possibility of religion
of and specifically of christianity
i mean i think that you could go further
with this and say that you know maybe
christianity shouldn't be the only
religion that philosophy
has to have a similar
you know relation to in this respect but
um
you know maybe maybe many others
um
[Music]
not necessarily every single uh
religious aspect but certainly some of
them so
yeah so those are some some good
questions i mean blondel's work oxiano
is going to get
revised later on
um
yeah any any other questions comments
um
thing thoughts this is provoked you know
this is as i mentioned this is the
second to last um
one that we're going to be going into
i'm going to show you the table of
contents real quick so we are
getting close to the very end you see
blown dell's thing there leon noel is
next i'm not going to read the
bibliography to you that would be
extremely boring you know
um
so all right
thomas gerard who would be a thinker who
took up blondel's torch was anyone
directly influenced by him
thousands of people were directly
influenced by him he is often called the
philosopher of vatican ii
um
transcendental tomism
uh starting with like joseph maraschal
is heavily engaged with blondel you'll
find references to him in rahner in
lonergan
and in others as well
there was actually a contribution made
in the debates uh looking at blondel and
husserl by joseph marshall and you
recall of course that joseph marshall
was one of the people who
was engaged in blondel's
session with the associated detude
philosophy
let me see if i can find this marshall
piece
um and and then he's just one yeah here
we go it's uh phenomenal feminine
phenomenology pure
philosophy
in philosophy parents
[Music]
published in sort of a fashrift right
uh who else was influenced by blondel
all the nouveau theology people you know
which would include andrei de lubac
um there's also you know some of the
people involved in this debate antonin
sertian is drawing from blondel
um if you've ever read john paul the
seconds you know the pope's fides hit
rozzio the piece on christian philosophy
blondel is not mentioned there and
somebody pointed out that
um
[Music]
that's because the entire document is
drawing on blondel's perspective so you
know blondel it was massively
influential
um mark
would i ever consider doing a reading
series like this about my phd i'd be
interested to hear more about blondel
well if you mean my dissertation my
dissertation
it was not a document that i was really
happy with it was kind of a
mishmash of really three different
things that probably should have been
done you know in separation from each
other it's also in word perfect so i
would have to convert it to word
so
i don't think i'll probably ever do that
absalom the problem for western bible
readers today is we don't think like
ancient jews from their mindset they
could have easily more found an
explanation of how could jonah survived
in a whale totally irrelevant to this
and uh generalizing in super broad
senses about uh how people read things
there's there's you know
dozens of hermeneutics out there today
many of which actually you know are
attuned to thinking trying to think the
way that is
what we call form criticism right so
yeah not not really
uh
relevant to this
um any other questions comments we had
about another seven minutes um
about the book about blondel about the
debates you know any of that sort of
stuff
all right so
mark says from a christian perspective
do you think a full love of christ is
possible without philosophia
um
that's an interesting question i mean
for the people involved in these debates
philosophia not in the sense of the
discipline of philosophy but the love of
wisdom is in fact going to involve
love of you know what is
best and wisdom that can communicate
itself and traditionally that has been
understood to be christ as a matter of
fact when you read you know for example
the deuterocanonical jewish text the
wisdom of solomon and wisdom is
personified there is you know debates
among christians is this the second or
the third person of the trinity or is
this something different you know like a
highest creature or stuff like that so
you know traditionally the word the
logos has been understood as
as wisdom um
could you say could you and we could say
can you
do this without explicitly um focusing
on christ i would say the answer is yes
and certainly blonde dell seems to think
the answer is yes but you're going to
get more mileage
um out of it you know
so yeah
that's a good question there's a lot a
lot more there that could be
drawn out i'll say that
there's sort of a you know for for a lot
of um
christian philosophers there's a
convergence that's going on you could
say
all right uh darth vader how important
is it to understand hegel from the point
of view of christianity instead of using
his dialectic to filter out all the
christianity from it it's not important
at all to understand hegel from the
point of view of christianity i think
um
it's you know hegel's worth knowing and
understanding um he's got some
interesting thoughts rather you know
idiosyncratic about christianity
probably the best of his thoughts about
it are to be found replicated in foyer
bach
but why would you use his dialectic to
filter all the christianity from hegel's
views given that hegel
makes religion in the revealed religion
the penultimate to philosophy
that would be anti-hegel it would be
like betraying hegel's own point of view
uh thomas it's interesting how vatican
ii drew from these thinkers from the
perspective of faith it's kind of a
little green light as far as the
philosophy is concerned
i'm not really sure what you mean by a
little green light
um
you know prior to vatican ii this is
prior to vatican ii there was an
incredible fertility to
catholic philosophy it wasn't all
um given the competing views at the time
garagu lagrangianal gary gulagaraj was
was at the lunatic fringe of things he
was not mainstream
um
people who like like to talk about him i
usually just dismiss
them he's got so he's got a good book on
the spiritual life but when it came to
like the debates of the time garagu
lagrange admitted he like
couldn't understand blown down but had
no problem you know condemning him the
mainstream was more people like the ones
that are actually in in this work you
know joseon maraten sertian uh it was
massively important at the time
um non non uh um
uh thomas philosophers like atien bourne
and uh mach shaler
and
uh edith stein well she kind of is
thomas in a way
maurice blondell of course you know
gabriel and marcel were massively
important as well
um
all right darth vader what do you think
of somebody like zizek's reading of
christianity i don't know what gg's
reading of christianity is because he
checks all over the map all the time
um i don't know that he has a coherent
reading of christianity as far as i can
tell
so and it's you know doesn't have
anything to do with
the more rigorous stuff that you find
here so
all right any other questions we've got
about two more minutes left
okay
um
well i'm waiting to see if anybody has
anything to say so one more session and
we're going to be reading
leah noel's uh piece which is drawing on
who's real by the way interestingly the
notion of christian philosophy
um daniel how does the new does the
nouvelle theologia emerge from this
debate no it emerges from people
who are
reading the people who are in this
debate the debate itself already
involves you know henry de lubeck at the
end of it so
uh darth vader how important is
kierkegaard in the history of
christianity you know kind of important
kind of not important like like so many
figures he's pretty late in the history
of christianity right
um
[Music]
he's interesting he's got a lot of cool
stuff to say
a lot of what he has to say when you
look at it is not totally original he
doesn't claim that it actually is i mean
he in in philosophical fragments he's
like
begging the readers um pardon for not
being original and and just saying stuff
that lochtancius or luther or people
like that said thomas gerard is this a
fruit of attorney potress attorney
potress is a
um
papal encyclical back in the 1800s yeah
it's partly
it's it's not a fruit of it it's
certainly coming out of
a uh
a milieu in which attorney potress
put tomism back on the map
um and spurred an interest in
neo-scholasticism
i talk about the attorney pontras in the
historical introduction
in the
general background and the debates
french context
so all right well it is one o'clock i
gotta get some other work we'll be doing
one more of these uh next week
and that will end this uh this series
that i started back
in the summer and the fall
in 2011
uh because the book is now you know 10
years old so all right i'll see all of
you next time hopefully and good
conversation